Oh
fine and welcome to the third episode of
the weekly Google klappa from podcast
i'm your host francisco and i'm here
with the other hast mark hey Mark how
are you doing I'm good friends sku doing
pretty good that's good I hear you're a
little bit out and about at the moment
here you're traveling I know you're not
in San Francisco yeah I've been falling
for quite a bit ten days already
somewhere in Europe I went to a dev in
Sweden and then GTG that fasting mount
and now I'm in Paris for the go oh
sounds like a tough life I am here in
San Francisco in my living room yeah it
could be worse for you it could it could
be a lot worse it could be a lot lower
that sounds like you're having lots of
fun well we've got a we've got a great
interview lined up with with one of our
teammates but why don't we talk about
our cool thing in the week before we get
stuck into that sure so the cool thing
of the week is that we've got a new
cloud console you I the what we call the
new cloud management console yup have
you have you got to use it a little bit
i have i've been using it for a little
while now I quite like it it's very
pretty lots of nice looks really pretty
that's where it's really really for you
every single logo has a slightly
different color I actually really like
that yeah yeah so if you want to get the
chance to use it there's a little try
that made a console button that you can
press a little switch over your console
can always switch back it's no
commitment it's okay but no it's it's
really nice I really my favorite feature
i think i have to i have two favorite
features but being able to pin things at
the top so i use App Engine alerts so
being able to go pee in an app engine so
I can quickly get to it really quickly I
really like that and i'm going to guess
the second one is it the search bar
actually this in the search bar but the
search part is awesome the search bar is
my favorite one so okay so if it's not
the search bar what is it okay so i
actually really like on the front page
you can customize your widgets so you
can specify the edge it's on the front
page that you want to see so that you
can get all your up-to-date information
about say like evers or what's the set
to Google cloud platform or any lesser
stuff so you get that as a glance as you
first joint that's really cool yeah
that's that's wiggle I guess we're just
different people I'm more like I just
want to find whatever i'm looking for
without having to set every anything up
well you're more like painting and
that's true defying and customizing but
yeah for whatever you like doing
basically you happen so that's fun i
love one thing i do love about the
search bar though is there are shortcut
keys so there's a shortcut key that
takes you to the search bar and then you
can enter in so you want to look at a
pension or whatever you want to talk to
really quickly so the combination of the
shortcut keys and the search bar means
you can navigate around the dashboard
really really quickly without having to
touch a mouse just really actually they
not know that and now all of a sudden
very interesting what what's the
shortcut do you even know what ah I
can't remember off the top of my head I
have to I have I have to find it yeah
that sounds good that sounds actually
really useful because I really yeah I
I'm a famed user I don't like Mouse's
mice mice english is hard yep so no I am
I totally I totally love it so that is
that is cool so there you go there's
three features that I love cool ya go so
yeah the pinning the customizing and
then the search bar oh it's just forward
slash forward slash type and set open it
up and then you can talk like app engine
or what if you like and it hit enter
it's just forward slash it's really a
forward slash you know that that's
actually that's actually the the key to
also searching fame right is it okay I'm
not even be a site that's perfect okay
I'm gonna egg on I thought I use that
wonderful okay great so we had a show
her head oh good no you go I was gonna
say probably exactly the same thing you
were we recorded a interview earlier
this week early last week actually with
one of our teammates Brian Dorsey yeah
we have a yeah we had a great photo
Brian Dorsey the Brian Dorsey yes we had
a great chance to chat with him about
communities yeah so what do you think
should just stop playing that interview
them that's a great idea let's play that
interview right now so we are joined
today by one of our wonderful colleagues
Brian Dorsey who is also a developer
advocate for the
Google cloud platform we're gonna have a
chat today about communities and Google
container engine how you doing today
Brian excellent thanks for having me in
charge now of course the first question
I have to ask before anything we go on
is is it Cooper Nidhi's or crew
benetti's I argue about this all the
time I think that's probably the most
important thing that we discussed for
anything else yeah I think I'm gonna
mangle this I think I met a Greek
gentleman who said it the actual Greek
word is pronounced something like
Gurunath is but you know it's something
that was berthed on the west coast
united states so we pretty much say
goober Nettie's Wanda okay so before we
go on any further why don't you give us
a brief background on yourself so people
know who you are you know you're not
popular enough already oh so hi I'm
Brian I'm a developer advocate for
Google cloud platform and you have
worked on a few different things you
know cloud storage our compute engine
virtual machines and lately been doing a
lot of work with container engine cooper
Nettie's also a love spice on and go so
good so that was that works right that's
that works that sounds good Francis
loves to go as well ya wena yeah little
comment on the on the name I just came
back from ccp next in paris and french
people actually call it could be on it
um I thought that was really cute I
found out awesome that it's also cooler
than it in in Hebrew there you go it's
kid I like it I probably mangled that as
well we should make an international
international / NCA shin like
downloadable guide or something like
that that would be hysterical that would
be actually don't like that way that
sounds really good so we should probably
talk about what communities actually is
and why people should care about it and
why basically all three of us think it's
pretty awesome so since since you're the
guest on the show Brian why don't you
take us away I sweet so I mean I think
the the the big picture thing is like
context wise you know more and more
people have access to you know lots and
lots of computers and most software
today's is running across you know is
already a distributed system like your
you're running different processes on
multiple machines and keeping track of
all this is a challenge and so you know
at a very high level Cooper Nettie's
helps you basically run your software
your processes on a whole cluster of
computers but reason about all of them
as one thing as one entity so you can
say hey I want to run you know five
copies of this process could win of
these make that happen somewhere in the
cluster make sure they stay running
anything goes wrong let me know restart
them one of the Machine goes down
reschedule them that's really cool so
that actually sounds a little bit like
what we do here at Google a little bit a
little bit yeah like having a lot of
machines and trying to run some stuff on
it so I heard a lot of people saying oh
yeah Cooper Nettie's is just the open
source version of up what we do here I
could which is bored is that true I in
in the like philosophically absolutely
so it's like in its inspired by bored
but it is a you know from the ground up
actually more modern implementation of a
lot of these ideas yeah and in fact
there's a fantastic talk we can add the
links to the show note by john wilkes
talking about the relationship of borg
and what it looks like as a developer at
Google to write code and run that on our
clusters and then you know what we've
built with Cooper Nettie's so it's a fun
talk like diving deep into that mat
relationship that's cool so communities
it came from google i don't know that
much about the history itself but i know
i believe Red Hat's been involved and a
few other companies do you know more
about like where it was conceived and
and that sort of background stuff
absolutely so um you know basically
three very senior folks at Google just
noticed this kind of trend of the rest
of the world you know kind of running
into these same situations that the
google had you know a way of dealing
with internally and decided you know to
try to prototype up building a kind of a
you know an initial version of that that
everybody could use and then you know we
actually
vinced the the company to release that
as an open source project so you know
that it runs entirely on our our cloud
platform and now AWS and a juror and
your own Hardware lots of other places
but it's very much taking the
philosophies of how Google run software
and releasing that is an open source
project and so it started with a few
engineers at Google and now as you said
you know red has involved core OS is
involved you know dozens actually have
companies and the far more individuals
from lots of other places actually let's
just take a look real quick at the
github repo which now has ten thousand
stars you know 2700 Forks it nineteen
thousand seven hundred commits as a few
people of it just a few people yeah it's
an extremely active open source project
and you know we had our 10 release
earlier this summer and heading very
close to the 11 release now cool so from
a from a more down-to-earth bun of you
like Cooper night it sounds really cool
it allows you to run stuff on machines I
know that the stuff itself it's
basically docker containers right right
that's the primary you know contaminate
like okay uh what one of the things can
you run actually actually so yeah so um
you know the the rocket container format
that's kind of from core OS supported
and then it they've been moving like
towards consolidating on so both darker
and rocket another folks are kind of
moving to kind of standardizing some
container formats so you know Cooper
nice is intended to run multiple
container formats but definitely
primarily what people are running is
docker containers cool so so okay so
then we're running containers mainly
docker but not necessarily and and
cabernet this allows us to just manage
them what what does that even mean like
what you do with good night and what's
that look like from like a developer and
operations perspective right so yeah so
the container gives us a kind of
hermetically sealed
you know container a little box for our
processes so just starting their like
you it is kind of amazing because you
have a process that every time it starts
it has the same context right it always
sees the same file system and that gets
us all kinds of great benefit swoop and
you know one of those is you can run
that same package on different computers
and get the same result right which is a
huge pain in normally um and then what
Cooper neighs really brings in is it
keeps track of all these things and it
helps them find each other and in a very
high level it lets you talk about your
whole cluster declaratively so when
you're actually using Cooper Nettie's
you write a config usually in ya moul
can also view Jason you say okay I've
got this container that has the version
of the software i want to run i would
like you to run you know five or eight
copies of this somewhere in the cluster
and i want to make you need to make sure
that they stay running and you know go
and then you kind of push that
declaration off to cooper Nettie's and
then from then on it's cooper Nettie's
job to make sure that that that
requested state stays true right so if
one of those containers dies it will
restart it if one of the hosts goes away
it will actually you know start up new
ones somewhere else and so that lets you
you know in a very real sense you know
sleep more because the system is
maintaining the you know the way you
asked it to be set up instead of just
kind of a one-time hey run these things
then you have to like manually somehow
figure out how to or up with your
automation make sure that they're
running queries tix here that I think
that's a two things you kind of said
that the really resonate with made
something I really like about
communities the kind of dizzy co systems
one of which is you've got this darker
format that's kind of ubiquitous I think
that's that's incredibly powerful and
when you said oh you're talking about
you know coming from Borg to communities
they're able to look at it and say okay
these are common things that people are
doing in terms of scale in terms of
managing computers cluster of stuff like
that I'm putting those two things
together it doesn't matter what that
application inside that docker container
looks like it can be as a unique
individual snowflake is you know you
make you make you know in
your own little workspace but then once
you sort of wrap that up you can just
become the superior this format that you
can do standard things with and you're
no longer going i need a scaling
solution for review or I need a scaling
solution for node or any disk ailing
solution for my particular app that's
very unique and special you can take
advantage of these pretty awesome tools
which i think is super super powerful
exactly and if you're if you're def
workflow you know so like you've got
developers you know working and then
you've got testers you know you know
actually testing and make sure brother
things work may be the same folks and
then operations folks like no matter
which pieces of software the different
containers use you can use the same
process across all of those you know and
you know really we all want to kind of
choose the best tool for the job or
different teams you know in a real
service or your network structure you
know might choose to use different tools
and let this lets you manage them all
you know that's kind of one of the
fundamental like benefits of docker and
containerization yeah one of the things
that I really like about coronaries is
the fact that what you were saying is
this concept of desired state we're
basically rather than having to you
handles like oh this machine went down
let me go and we start this job
somewhere else that's that's going to be
automated directly and that's cool but
something which i think is even cooler
and I've seen some demos of it but I
think you could explain a little bit
more what it is it's this concept of
rolling updates now I've seen that I
sent that at Google but I have never
seen that outside of Google it's super
powerful so so you know so we've got
desired state right and when we first
set up the thing you know I told it I
you know I want I want five web
front-ends right um but that that number
you can change that over time so you can
think of it as like there's a dial like
a volume knob you know on your processes
you can like well let's turn that up to
11 and you know you get all the
processes right right and so you can
kind of turn it up and down there so
that just gets you you're scaling right
away so you just tell Co brunetti so I
want eight now and I want three now and
then the rolling update so as you have
new versions of your software you can
basically say okay I'm going to create a
new definition for this new version and
Cooper days I want you to slowly start
adding more of these and I'll watch the
logs
and as long as everything's going well
we'll just slowly replace the old ones
with the new ones and then we'll have a
new version in production and so that's
pretty powerful but since these
containers are hermetically sealed I
think that you know they're they're
isolated there that they're loose one
thing so you can do this atomic upgrade
right where you just you know replace
the previous version with the new one
but the crazy thing is a rollback is
actually the exact same process so go
into a nice previous version is the same
right that that blows my mind ello this
especially someone I've hand-rolled
stuff behind a load balancer just
because I haven't either at the time
with the inclination or the pain point
to actually go in order to make this
stuff so being able to just go oh well
this thing gives me a way to rolling
update behind a load balancer or
whatever it's in front of you know like
that's that super powerful again again a
generic solution for a problem yet we've
encountered anywhere i look so like
let's like dive on generic solution a
bit so like we talked about kind of like
Ronnie's processus lets you know it's
basically like a you know a system d or
a process manager you know kind of thing
right but across a whole bunch of
machines but you also have to figure out
where these things are so if you want to
connect them up to a load balancer like
you mentioned you know you you have to
do that connection somehow use to tell a
load balancer so could wear these
handles that as well so you know as you
make this definition you also make this
definition just called a service and
that the convert entities is aware of
where these things are actually running
and handles the plumbing for the kind of
cable load balancer to it and that also
gives you this nice static name which is
also a dns name and IP address so you
can have each of the different parts of
your system have a static name but the
actual you know where those things exist
you know that changes over time you know
so it might be running here might be
right there and your software does
enough to care you've got a known
location to talk to your cash and known
location talk to your database known
location to talk to web front-ends and
communities get kind of handles all that
and then you can plumb logging through
and all kinds of fun stuff so yeah I
guess that that's a difference between
schedulers and cabernet is right like
corona is not just scheduling absolutely
tigers it's actually a little bit
more than that because there's service
like services basically service
discovery yes you get that already
inside of coordinators you don't need to
add another layer on top so they take a
step back for those not familiar with
the term scheduling oh I explain what
that is so yeah basically scheduling
could be I want to run five of five
copies of failure and then just run them
if one of the machines goes down then
just move that container somewhere else
but then I want to be able to say oh
yeah you know it's like I'm gonna send a
request those requests should be handled
by one of those five containers are
running yep well if they keep on moving
how do I target them so a service is
basically just a way of saying i'll just
send senator to this service and grenada
just will find whoever is behind us so
they intelligently rounds through and
what I really like is the fact that the
way you define it is via a very simple
concept which Stags and that's so
beautiful it's basically just tag stuff
saying I was like this is a back end it
is a front end or this is something for
tests and then you can create services
saying oh yeah target all the front end
that are also text or things like that
which is really simple but at the same
time you're so powerful that so very
nice to use and yeah those are key part
of the rolling update and helps you do
kind of like it your people who do kind
of red black upgrades that sort of thing
you also kind of mentioned you know
another part of scheduling is you know
making sure that you know you put
thieving processes in a place where
they're going to be successful right you
put them on a machine that's not too
busy that has enough memory that works
and so many wait on our team describes
that as you know you're kind of playing
tetris with your your recesses right
you've got these oddly shaped
combinations of cpu and memory and and
disc requirements and then they need to
fit in these certain size boxes that are
the actual nodes you're running the the
software on and you want to maximize
that because that's the most efficient
it's going to save you the most money
and it quickly becomes this you know
kind of multi-dimensional complex game
of Tetris and yeah I really like that
comparison with Tetris
I don't know if you have seen kelsey is
our gave a really good talk talking
about Cooper Nettie's and at Hoshi Cove
hmm and he actually played Tetris that's
my pretty good yeah let it super
Princess to bring home the same plan of
ya like it it's hard to do but it's
automated but I think we actually had a
cloudspinner win so if people have ever
seen out loud spin demo yeah we were
running it on virtual machines for a
long time to our video processing and we
shifted it to communities and I think we
got something like a three times less
resource usage it was something that
yeah yeah i mean when i created the the
demo basically was like I just need to
get it working so I did something that
I'm sure most of us has done before have
done before which is I'm running one
container per machine yep yep anything
machine goes down just restarted that's
it yeah that was it but yeah we're
spending we're spending a serious amount
of money because you know like you're
using one machine for a container we
actually know what you want to do and
with good Burnett is basically we ended
up with just three hearts and all
containers same amount of containers so
same performance that you used to have
but automated over only three instances
not and that's that was really really
nice and really easy to do so yeah very
very cool ok so uh I guess we should
probably stop talking about like Google
container engine all right google google
container with a cage yeah it is a
google cloud platform Yogcast yeah
actually so good we should talk about
that so like people sometimes abbreviate
Google container engine as gke yes so
you can think about is kind of like
Google Cooper Nettie's engine yep in a
way oh and you know so the main you know
difference there so it's running you
know so container engine is hosted
Cooper Nettie so it's running the you
know surgical Burnett ease but we handle
running the master for you so we you
know maintain that we keep it up-to-date
we upgrade you know the company's
software itself over time just kind of
basically handle you can think about
actually using Cooper Nettie's it kind
of
two parts there's there's one part that
is you know setting up the cluster
itself and running Cooper neighs and
then the other part is like running your
software in Cooper Nettie's so you're
kind of like you know that the
configured setup and maintenance of the
cluster itself first is actually using
the cluster and you know actually
internally Google it's two separate
groups you usually manage those things
right you've got the people to run all
the clusters and then you've got the
application groups who actually run
their software in the clusters so in
this is a way of basically you know
letting Google run goo brittany's for
you so you can focus on your app so you
mentioned that a one of the things that
Google container engine does is create a
cluster if you were to create your own
cluster like what do you do you get like
a half I don't know 55 machines in my
premises right how hard is it to get it
working so it so the them so they're a
couple things you get so Cooper is kind
of comes you know out of the cloud kind
of world right and so there's some stuff
you get you know in those environments
so whether that's you know on google
cloud or on you know other folks clouds
you you get the dynamic like creation
and removal of machines you get api's
for controlling networks and and those
are actually kind of the two main
benefits that are a little more that are
kind of contrasting to running on your
own machines so the network in
particular can be a little bit of a
challenge right now when you're setting
up your own stuff one of the things
Cooper Debbie's does is it gives every
pod so every every collection of
containers has its own IP address and so
that's really helps simplify the
scheduling because you don't have to
ever deal with pork conflicts or
whatever if you know two different
things are listening on port 80 you know
they're trying to be web servers you can
still scheduled on the same machine
because I get their own IP address in
turn though that means that Cooper
neighs itself needs to have some control
over that work it's not super common you
know in people's you know physical data
centers a lot of times so people often
run an overlay Network like final or
kind of change the way the the load
balancing and the networking works a
little bit to do that so it's usually
kind of probably the main challenge
other than that you know it's
a go program and we've got setup guides
for a whole bunch of different
environments up on Cooper Nettie's do so
and so there's there's some guys on
everything you have to install some
software make sure that the machines are
well connected and all the networking
stuff which is really hard for me to do
I'm not a networking guy you have to set
that up with ji ke a group of theta
engine how long does it take to create a
cluster that's five minutes you know so
you know and most of that's just you
know machine starting up in scripts
running and that sort of thing so you
know it's about a minute of your time so
you kind of log into the cloud console
go over to navigate your way down the
side bar two containers and give it a
name how many nodes you want to have in
it what size you know computers those
notes are how many processes first they
have and hiccup and you're ready to run
your containers in there that's nice
yeah it's also the only way I've ever
fired a humanities cluster I've never
tried to manually do it yet yeah so
brave on that note like you know no
matter where you're planning on running
cover Nettie's long-term and I think one
of the big advantages of Coober Nettie's
is that you know it gives you some
consistency to environment for running
your software so you can run it in
multiple different cloud providers you
can run down your machines you can run
it on your laptop you know so you can
you can run the same system in a lot of
different places but if if you're kind
of like trying to decide whether or not
this is something you even want to spend
the time on doing your first experiments
in Google container engine is just so
much easier to tell whether you even
care about commodities like whether you
want to spend the time to set it up on
your own stuff yeah so I highly
recommend that no matter where you plan
on on deploying yeah I agree a hundred
percent I've seen more than a few people
do that and yeah one of the lovely
thinks about communities is that you can
pick it up and move it which is great so
well we would love for you to stay on
Google cloud platform we understand it
people have needs that's fair enough but
yeah it's just such an easy process to
get get you know three or four notes
spun up and start deploying things get
playing with it Square and
for me one of the things that I really
like is uber Nettie's is something that
I really like to play with meg I know
that there's some people that are
already using in production for our demo
the Google classroom we're using it in
production which is cool but for me
right now it's like I'm learning the
concepts and playing with it and and the
good thing is that the pricing for
Cooper net is if you just want like not
for community sorry for container engine
up to five hosts which is a decent
amount of hosts already 0 so you don't
pay anything so like anything if you
want to play with it you can create your
heart your cluster quite easily get your
machines running and then start playing
with it so I buddy anything i'll add a
little bit there you don't pay anything
for container engine itself yeah deuce
you'll pay for the virtual machines that
you're running oh yeah which might be
running yeah then you get to choose how
big or small your machines you want like
we discussed in previous podcast
previous episode yeah absolutely yeah so
you can you can choose really small
machines and make that very very like
low cost and you combine that with a
free trial or something like that yep
definitely gives you enough time to to
play with it yeah it's lots of fun
really or you could fire up 32 core you
know nothing give a sign of them 532
core and end up with 170 cores something
that's a decent amount of course yeah
yup I not gonna be fine let's play that
sounds like that says a look a lot of
fun all right so that sounds that sounds
pretty cool I'm I'm definitely sold not
that I wasn't before of course for a
difficult container engine um there's a
road map I had a look at it it looked
like you know they're sleeping for a 1.1
release in what was it late October I
can't remember off the top of my head
what features were coming um Brian think
you're guessing you're closer to those
that there any particular things that
you're looking forward to you think
you're going to be particular exciting
for people absolutely there's a bunch of
stuff coming looks like early November
kind of timeline okay yeah the 11
release that's early November 2015
depending what your listen listen to
this like yeah such a far away right
person so they are
for continuing work on you know kind of
just straight up scalability you know so
the 10 release they were you know kind
of guaranteeing that everything worked
really well up to 100 host nodes and
they're they're kind of pushing that up
to run to 50 plus you know lots of
people are running larger but they're
you know kind of conservatively you know
we've tested everything you know all the
corner cases are happy you know at this
size and above so they're putting are
pushing their you know improving you
know networking forms a few places you
know support for later you know newer
docker releases the 1.8 X series of
things so the schema validation and you
know new API is and things like that a
couple things I wanted to call out in
particular is a kind of like there's a
hook that you can you can basically set
up an HTTP listener or run a script
right before a pod is shut down you know
so sometimes though so sometimes your
your your code you know Corinne days
decides that you need to get off this
host and so that if it's a planned event
you'll get a hook so you can kind of
some stuff to do the days go whatever
your thing yes nice so that's super nice
there's a new job object coming so this
is you know go to the building blocks
for more batch operations so you know
right now Cooper neighs is kind of
focused on long running processes the
job option object like really brings in
you could always run you know a single
you know container single pod to
completion you know just say I want to
run this and make it happy and it's you
know careers has always been able to do
that but the job object allows you to
manage you know a large number of jobs
that you might want to only run a subset
at a time to completion so you know you
can set up you know Q workers you can
set up you know you know if you want to
run you know a thousand instances of
something you know but you only have
room to run 25 at them at a time you can
use this to manage that so you do like
chrome type things for you want to do
something like once every hour or
something like that so I don't I'm not a
warrior of a cron right now okay that's
a small like almost like mapreduce stuff
yes
a lot of things to do but not in a very
sources so absolutely yeah so you could
you can definitely do MapReduce II kinds
of things you know a lot of deer
processing sort of things it's
definitely nice Alex hitting those
targets like cron is super easy to
implement with Cooper neighs by the way
because you can basically take your
configure that thing you want to do and
you can run cube control and just say
create this pod run to completion as
NASA and you know just put that in a
cron somewhere and that'll do its thing
and then the other one I really want to
call out is auto scaling of pods so you
know you get a lot of requests for that
yep so you can you can basically say you
know I want to run no fewer than this
many and no more than this many but
within that range run enough to keep you
know memory or CPU targets in this
general area and then it will kind of a
screw this up and down that's really
cool so that's the big stuff comin cool
very exciting alright I think we're
probably coming to a close brian is
there anything else about communities or
a container engine you want to mention
we haven't really touched on yet I've
covered a pretty good chunk i just
wanted to recommend people check out
cooper Nettie's I oh it is a bunch of
docs and good information there and also
the communities github site there's also
you know criminy's is very active on
slack so you can get that and get that
info from communities at i/o so but you
know please join us kind of play with
things see how kind of you know mapping
your apps to this world works if you've
you know gotten woken up at night to
have to restart something I definitely
get Cabernets dry wonderful and if
you'll want to contact you directly
Brian Jerry mail yet so there you met so
i'm i'm brian with an i so bri a and do
our suy on twitter and you can also you
know Brian Dorsey at google com go Willa
well that all of those things that just
mention to to the show note I heard
something about the Coronet is black
which I'm not sure if it's true or not
is it true that they actually have one
engineer all the time they're like
rotating not always the same person so
they always have someone from the team
to answer questions so
the committee's team is is fantastic and
you know in addition to slack in a few
other things you know part of being
secondary oncall is is you know working
on social media as I can I help you know
people famous like get three things so
I'm not gonna make the guarantee it's
like absolutely always but that's part
of the you know I call rotation and then
there's just like you know founders the
team and like there's just so many
people who are really really engage and
then the community is growing so large
right now that you know whether or not
you get a google engineer there like
there are experts in Cooper neighs
they're very active and and helping
people out all the time I'm not so nice
really excited about how the community
is you know come together to really you
know help people solve problems and make
make their stuff happen so very cool I
know I'm in there I've seen I'm pretty
sure I've seen you in there so Brian I'm
actually not there you're not there yeah
I'm very quiet well yeah so yeah thank
you so much Brian I think haha and
hopefully will interview you sometime
soon about the next version with cooler
things of coronaries or maybe we can
interview you about something else cuz
you know so much stuff anyway that
that'd be doable listen I'm having about
and you know we can bring some folks
from the committee's teams so if anybody
out there has somebody specific they
want to hear from let us know and we'll
bring them on definitely and if anyone
has any questions about communities
please fire them through we always need
questions of the week so we'd love to
have those on the podcast as well
wonderful well thank you very much Brian
I think we'll end things there but we
appreciate you being the timer's white
boys thanks so much to Brian for joining
us and having a chance to chat to us
about couperin need ease but we have a
great question that's come in from one
of our listeners and Alex Van voxel he's
asked us we have a lot of data in
bigquery and he's looking to divide the
data into buckets / date he's quite
aware that a table can never be too big
because bigquery is awesome but he's
wondering whether it could be too small
what's what is the size that is too
small for big
query so I think this is a really
interesting question yeah that's that's
the kind of question I'm very crucified
because i didn't really know the answer
yeah so we had a we had a chat with a
few people about this and they had a few
different perspectives which I thought
were quite cool um we we had what about
one of our teammates Philippe brought up
a very interesting point that he pointed
out in the documentation he said that
charges are rounded to the nearest
megabyte with a minimum of 10 megabytes
data process per table so something to
keep in mind when doing stuff with
bigquery so if you have tables with
really small amounts of data you're
always going to get charged the minimum
of 10 megabytes per query yeah nowadays
no I don't think that anyone actually
has a table with less than 10 megs but
if you do yeah it's good it's good to
keep in mind yeah well I think I think
that could come up if people leave their
data normalized and having like small X
a status tables you know you'd normally
do that stuff like that so you could get
ones that way yeah yeah so good to take
it look good to take care of that yeah
yeah and and we also asked one of the
solution solution engineers here google
for work terrance and what he said that
he was that indeed that was not too
small which again it's not there's
nothing to small there's nothing too big
like it's bigquery it just handles
everything you want but that his rule of
thumb its run 100 gigabytes so if you
have less than that it's not probably
worth charting and over that it starts
making sense so if you have like 100 of
some eggs probably you good if you start
having terabytes then that's where you
should definitely start charting a
little bit in it ya know that sounds
good and for those who are as familiar
with bigquery bigquery has some great
like tooling and built-in for running
queries across tables that have date
formats in them so you don't have to be
afraid of shouting which is nice but it
just makes it sort of a little bit yeah
a little bit better if you I just
actually it may be it may be a good idea
to give it a short short description of
a bit queries it's one of my favorite
Google cloud platform products actually
yup cars basically
it allows you to do sequel like requests
so if you know how to write sicko
statements you're good basically but if
you're gonna enter if you're gonna query
terabytes of data instead of taking
minutes or hours it just takes seconds
yeah that's that's fun no we had we had
a really good chat recently with some
people about the Korean where was the
right place would be query and i think
that the takeaway from that was you have
such large data sets that is taking new
hours to process them bigquery can allow
you to know hey not worry that
infrastructure because we manage that
for you but take those hours and move
those down in two seconds which which i
think is really powerful that it's
basically what we use in telling me i
could go to query hour or hour unlocks
and we do have a lot of logs so yeah big
data no problem with that yeah
definitely if you're interested in that
stuff go find one of our teammates
felipe he does amazing things wee's big
data especially I'm reddit especially he
does he does some really cool stuff yeah
we should have you on the show how far I
I was about to say that exactly we
need--we need one extra accent yep most
definitely so many people I want to have
an issue okay that sounds that sounds
pretty good yeah so um that sounds like
it's pretty much we're wrapping up we're
up doing out the the episode sounds good
agree with that i think so i think next
time we'll probably be in different
places yet again but that's okay i will
probably be in a different country yeah
so i'm gonna go tomorrow and gonna be on
my way to def hawks nice so if there's
anyone so in Antwerp in Belgium north of
Brussels so if there's anyone around
there we're gonna have I think we're
gonna be five people from our team so
that's gonna be fun they'll be great and
so if you're around and you want to chat
about Google+ platform just send me a
message and we'll be happy to do it to
get together what about you any any
traveling plans well I have an event
here in San Francisco end of the week I
will be a future stack which I'm really
excited about steve wozniak is going to
be keynoting them so super excited about
that and then after that I will be in
Philadelphia foreclosure
which I'm also really excited about so
oh yeah it's something about that
actually yeah you're gonna be talking
about continue rising you take over your
tools yeah container izing developer in
their development development
environment keep seeing a lot of people
doing lately I think it's really really
cool I'm actually I'm actually gonna be
next week at dr. Khan in barcelona where
I will be talking about continue rising
developer tools so yeah you're not the
only one wonderful all right Frances
thank you very much for joining me yet
again today very nice to talk to your
mark good I'll speak to you later
you